euh on va clôturer ce point people par
le fléo du moment les cambriolages de
chez les stars on en avait déjà parlé
dans l'émission du cambriolage qui avait
subi Bruno Guillon qui avait subi
également Vita et pendant les vacances
de Noël d'autres célébrités ont été
victimes de cambriolage Nicos Patrick
Sébastien cyine nignac Samina siriri
également bber le frelon euh on en parle
avec Mael et Michel Marie juste après
ce ces derniers jours la liste des
personnalités cambriolées ne cesse de
s'allonger C hommes ont été interpellés
après avoir tenté de cambrioler la
maison de l'animateur vedette de TF1
niikos si la semaine dernière niikos
Aliagas a été victime d'une tentative
d'ffraction certains ont bel et bien été
cambriolés à l'instar de Patrick
Sébastien où les malfras sont passés par
le jardin et dans la nuit du 26 au 27
décembre dernier aux abords de la tour
eel le domicile du chef pâtissier Cyril
Lignac a lui aussi été visité où des
montres et des sacs de luxe ont
notamment été dérobé pour un montant de
30000 €. c'est un voisin du pâtissier
qui le premier donne l'alerte il est
réveillé par un bruit de Briis de glace
alors nicoaliagas Patrick Sébastien
cyrilignac retour sur ses célébrités
victime de
cambriolage Michel oui bravo pour
l'élégance ça déjà c'est une chose après
on va parler des cambriages mais bravo
vous avez passé les vacances où chez moi
à la campagne gosse j'urais pas
l'adresse comp tenu de ce qui se
passe c'est tout
Michel il est sarcastique j'adore on va
parler donc des Cambri est-ce que vous
avez déjà été cambriolés vous ici jamais
jamais c'est vrai que il y a rien chez
vous je vous le dis n'allz pas
cambrioler Daniel Moron pour deux
statuettes et de de deux damars vous
faites pas chier ba non mais je vous le
dis une baignoire à porte franchement
les gars vous allez prendre des risques
pour pour rien oui moi une fois dans le
sud de la France ah ou ah oui j'étais là
et c'était pendant ouais vous étiez là
et c'était pendant le festival de Canam
donc c'était un soir les cambriolur
savaient que tout le monde était dehors
et ils ont pris plein de sacs moi je ch
jamais doncouis voilà et j'avais pas il
y avait pas de j'avais pas pris de
sécurité normal il y avait juste mes
chiens qui étaient là ils sont partis
ils ont eu les chiens ils ont tout pris
et voilà ouais ils ont pas eu peur des
chiensement chi par que j'avais que à
l'époque j'avais que des chiens gentils
et c'est il y avait des chiens qui
étaient hyper gros tout ça mais il
pensaent qu' chier dans la
piscine dire les cambrioleurs sont venus
ils sont lâché dans la piscine voilà
c'est tout ils ont pris ils ont pris
30000 € et j'ai jamais été remboursé tu
avais 300 € non mais de de de valeur
mais d' mec mettez vous foutez pas un
contrôle fiscal non plus c'est bon pas
d'espèces ici qui transit quoi croi
allez Michel euh et alors là Michel il
va nous expliquer des trucs de fou parce
que déjà merci et bravo pour le le
physique irréprochable euh il y a un
lien entre tous ces cambriolages ou pas
alors pas surtout ces cambriolages il y
a la la police judiciaire notamment la
police judiciaire de Versailles la BRB
de versaill BRB briillade de répression
du banditisme de la péchie de versaill
euh établit c'est dans l'affaire de de
cil Guillon de stphe Guillon Bruno Bro
Bro
[Rires]
gu Meur meilleur en cri
prénom W et donc
Guill
ou le le homejcking qui se doule
chez pas tour à Las
Vegas franchement donc d'accord ouais
donc vas-y ouais
donc vas-y vas-y cette nuit-là c'est
trois individus qui ont une arme de
point et qui vont euh ce qu'on appelle
saucissonner
euh le couple et trois enfants non c'est
la l'expression utilisé bien sûr bah oui
en charcuterie et donc
euh l'enquête de la de la police
judiciaire va conduire à
l'interpellation de trois individus
trois jeunes le plus jeune les 17 ans le
plus grand à le plus âgé à 22 ans ou 23
ans et grâce à un travail technique
extrêmement compliqué de téléphonie de
vidéosurveillance un lien avec une
voiture des surveillances enfin un
travail intense ils arrivent à
interpeller un type qui s'appelle camel
Z donc on n pas le droit de donner son
nom de famille qui a 27 ans qui est un
Parisien et qui serait le
commanditaire au moins de ce premier
home Jackie
il il le soupçonne sur un second sur
celui du du du champion de
MMA
AINS Cyril Gan et également sur celui
d'un d'un footballeur alors ce qu'il
faut comprendre en réalité c'est que ces
équipes qui sont des des équipes
criminelles hein c'est des équipes de de
banditisme se sont mis à la mode de de
l'époque où le banditisme fonctionnait
avec des fourgons avec des braquages de
banque et Cera tout ça n'existe plus
parce qu'il y a plus de fourgon ou en
tout cas il y a un nouveau système qu'on
va pas dévoiler forcément tu peux tu
peux bah c'est des voitures privées
anonymes qui transportent les fonds et
quand c'est des des
énormes des énormes transferts ils sont
sécurisés par des des escortes
policières et là il faut faudra les
attaquer avec avec un char d'assaut donc
les oou euh ne peuvent plus braquer les
banques ne peuvent plus braquer les
fourgons et donc ils sont recyclés il y
a les stupes mais les stupes il y a
aussi un problème c'est que toutes les
équipes sont extrêmement structurées et
du coup c'est un peu comme dans notre
société ils ont plus besoin de ils ont
ils sont ils sont fou donc du coup ils
se recycle c'est de la c'est du
recyclage dans ce type de de d'action
des actions qui vont très vite et qui
rapportent quelquefois beaucoup d'argent
alors Nico Salia c'était le le premier
cétait c'était vous avez des infos sur
euh non si ce n'est que toutes ces stars
heureusement n'étaient pas là parce que
quand on sait que pour Vita et pourino
Guillon ça a été ultra traumatisant
parce que Nico c'était le 1er janvier
c'est ça c'était du ouais du dans la
nuit du 1 au 2 et donc il était en Grèce
avec sa famille personne n'était là il y
a eu des dégradations mais ils ont pas
réussi à entrer il y a une une course
poursuite parce que les les enquêteurs
ont repéré une voiture de marque Citroën
garée pas loin et à l'issue de la course
poursuite ils ont réussi à interpeller C
personnes qui avaient dans leur voiture
tout le matériel nécessaire des colliers
de serrage du gros adhésif pour ce
qu'ils espéraient être un saucissonnage
Patrick Sébastien 21 décembre oui il
avait déjà été cambriolé 3 ans avant
chez lui à Boulogne ça avait été saccagé
là les gens sont rentrés par le jardin
dans sa propriété de 450 m² euh voilà
donc là ça n'a pas été dévasté
contrairement à 2019 il y a Cyril Lignac
aussi Cyril Lignac également donc 30000
€ ont été dérobés ça c'est dans le 7e
arrondissement de Paris des sacs de ha
cout ouais dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi et euh deux personnes ont été
interpellé euh il y avait des voisins
ont alerté pour des Briis de vert et la
police a pu intervenir et la BAC a
interpelé deux hommes il y a
saminaasséri également oui une tentative
là à vin scen pareil c'est les voisins
qui alerte à 1h du matin et quatre
cambrioleurs qui avaient des capuches et
un pied de biche pour rentrer chez lui
mais euh ils n'ont pas pu aller à
l'intérieur de la de la maison alors on
avait parlé a il y a Vita également euh
qui on en avait déjà parlé Alexandre Le
Tellier le gardien du un des gardiens du
PSG également voilà dans les ivelines
Sylvie Tellier Sylvie Tellier chez elle
également donc il y a eu aussi le une
tentative à Nice chez l'entraîneur de de
l'équipe de de football de l'équipe
première de de Nice voilà le système
d'alarme a raisonné et donc ça c'est au
moment où il y avait des matchs donc
voilà ils sont suivi on connaît leur
adresse et les gens savent qu'ils sont
en match ou sur le banc et en profitent
pour cambrioler ou tenter de le faire
oui Michel c'est comment ça se fait
qu'il y a de plus en plus de de
célébrités comme ça qui se font qui se
font parce que c'estci les les voyou
cibleent des est-ce que c'est les
réseaux sociaux qui joue pas du tout
alors les réseaux sociaux ont un rôle il
y a deux deux modes opératoires en gros
les réseaux sociaux où les gens sont pas
très prudents en indiquant qu'ils sont
pas chez eux ou en apparaissant en photo
avec une montre qui vaut 20 ou 30 ou
40000 € la voiture également en fait il
y a trois trois moyens il y a il y a ce
moyen là il y a l'information là je
pense qu'il faut vraiment faire très
attention à toutes ces plateformes de
livraison ah ça c'est intéressant ce que
va dire Michel alors écoutez bien les
plateformes de livraison des livou uber
oui je peux enfin tout le monde vous
vous vous faites livrer les pizzas d'un
Japonais chez vous euh vous donnez votre
code vous donnez des indications vous
donnez votre nom
euh et donc ces informations se
revendent alors pas systématiquement
évidemment mais il se trouve que parmi
les livreurs il y a des délinquants des
mecs qui ont un passé judiciaire il même
dans une affaire qui était fiché s quand
même donc on on est quand même sur des
sur des des gars qui ont un un passé
judiciaire et une volonté de nuire et de
de de faire mal et ces gens-là vendent
revendent leurs informations et à partir
de là bah c'est facile une fois que vous
avez l'adresse le code le nom
euh c'est souvent comme ça dans le temps
c'était la femme de ménage c'est le
petit copain de la femme de ménage qui
se faisait remettre le double des clés
et cetera mais ça c'est fini aujourd'hui
c'est par les les réseaux sociaux donc
faut faire très attention et à la limite
quand on livre on se fait livrer à
quelque chose l'idéal c'est de d'être
d'aller le chercher sur sur le trottoir
de décembre oui qu'est- de décembre non
non non c'est vrai que je le fais
maintenant parce que vous l'aviez vous
l'aviez conseillé l'autre jour je l'ai
déjà dit ouais oua oui une livraison et
tout ça en fait quoi qu'il advienne on
descend bas et on on fait pas monter la
personne en haut voilà alors